our last speaker who will national
markets will have sense bring together
some of the themes that we have been
discussing yesterday to the age is
Professor Martin Hagen marklin Hawking
teaches in the history department here
at Columbia University former director
of the Urban Institute which reached a
kind of a pudgy under marks directorship
was very active and mark was elected two
years ago I believe the person of the
International Association of Ukrainian
technical translation market I would
also like to start with some thanks
again to John MIT skill who's the
director of the sem to Europe Center to
Walter Savitsky from Ukrainian Congress
Committee to my assistant Maria sunny
hrvatska and to John's assistant Kevin
hallinan because without them this
wouldn't have all happened so on behalf
of all of us I'd like to thank them
about a dozen years ago Frank sisson as
part of his Ukrainian ization program
for me dragged me to a conference in
common its Podolsky which was one of the
first what was the first was the first
Congress of Ukrainian and polish
scholars in post-soviet conditions my
polish was a little better than my
cranial at that time which has since
changed but the atmosphere that
conference was still I think one of
rather aloofness between the two
national scholarly communities and that
has changed a great deal in the last 12
years fortunately as president of the
International Association Ukrainian
study that was elected in Chernivtsi as
the first non ukrainian in first non
diaspora president I haven't quite
figured out what that means yet or even
what my presidency meetings in many
senses but one thing that was very
rewarding about that presidency was my
first trip back to Poland last May in a
long time I had done research there in
archives and libraries for my own work
and studied polish as a as a graduate
student but I went for the first time in
about a dozen years again back to Warsaw
as president of Mao and everywhere I
went I was greeted as some sort of
Ukrainian American hero which I'm not
not ukrainian-american and I mean I am
American and I am president of his
association of Ukrainian studies but
what I saw happening in in Poland was a
confirmation of what had been hearing
for a long time that there's more
interest in Ukraine in Poland than
anywhere outside of Ukraine and
sometimes I
wonder if there's more interest even
than in Ukraine in Ukrainian things in
port at the University of Warsaw I
learned that there were a hundred ninety
students enrolled in Ukrainian studies I
doubt there is a Ukrainian university
let alone any other university outside
Ukraine where there are so many students
studying Ukrainian things and that's
only one University there's Lublin and
Catholic University the Union University
as you've heard which also have a great
deal going on in Ukrainian studies when
I went to the National Library the
director upon yeah yellow handed me a
book on Lisa belarus ukraine which he
wrote and how important it was for him
the director of the National Archives
similarly expressed great interest in
help to Ukrainian archives I went to a
book party for Yuri under Kovach's new
translation into you in the Polish part
of his polish national tour with a reply
at sea or was a diversity by now I think
and there must have been two hundred
young people there was it was more than
standing room only you could hardly
breathe in this place in Warsaw and two
nights later I went to another book
presentation by Alexandra machuca in the
battery foundation Warsaw for her book
project nanas Imperium which was also
packed with all sorts of warsaw
intelligence yet